the men's trio of aces has a combined
1.69 era that's a good formula for being
in first place in the middle of june see
the toyota numbers for taiwan walker the
mets are 5-0 in his starts at home this
year jack peterson's been on a home run
tear and it's peterson to lead off
against taiwan walker mind the other way
that's going to be a base hit falling in
front of dom smith
so dom plays it on the first hop and
peterson is aboard with a lead off
single now the mets overshift to the
left and the first pitch to the right
hand hitting brian inside it hit him
that's a very delicate area to be hit a
lot of little bones in there definitely
hit his hand it does not look like it
struck the bat before that so the first
two have reached against walker a single
and a hit by pitch and now javi baez
who's been battling an injury to his
right thumb he pinched hit last night
and ground it out swung at him
three you know walker went away with a
slider and javi baez as he often does
bit
and walker has the first out here at the
top of the first inning in there strike
three called walker where the sinker
catches the inside corner peterson at
third brian at second conference at
first with two out walker with a door to
get through the inning the one-two pitch
swung out in this strike three got him
with a fastball side retired well a
20-pitch top of the first for taiwan
walker
well alec mills for the cubbies you can
see his numbers land rover numbers for
alex mills he spent three weeks on the
il with a lower back strain hasn't
pitched since june 8. through no hitter
last year in september since that
no-hitter the zra is 6.48 33 in the
third inning big man hits the ground
ball toward the middle grabbed by baez
right near the bag actually that was
alcantara the cubs had the shift on
alcantara the second baseman grabbed it
stepped on the bag and that ends the
inning and
lindor shares a chuckle with his old
buddy javier baez and jason hayward will
try to start a cubs rally in the second
blind the first caught by alonso one man
away
oh that'll have hayward muttering under
his breath because he hit that one right
on the screws and alonso had to be quick
to put it away for the first down wisdom
is on the batter is javier baez no score
top of the third baez hits one in the
air to deep right field this ball's got
a chance gone
two-run rocket to right by javier baez
cubs lead two-nothing
that ball just jumped out of here
his 15th of the year and the cubs laid
by a pair little redemption for javi a
strikeout victim first time up with two
on and nobody out but he wastes no time
jumping on walker here just the third
home run
that taiwan walker has allowed this year
it's the 15th long one for javi baez a
no doubter here's
two outs two on pitch curve ball wide
toward the middle base it for alonzo
that'll tie up the game lendore and
smith come in to score
the lonzo with a two out two run single
on the mets get even two to two this is
not an over swing here
that is just going right with the pitch
and base hits all that's needed
and that's good hit situational hitting
32nd and 33rd rbis for alonso so after
the two-run homer by baez the mets get
the two runs right back let's see what
walker can do here the third time
through the chicago batting order and he
slaps another one on the left side vr
with a great extension and the throw on
targets
gorgeous play by jonathan villar to rob
peterson of a base hit
good range to the left and the
difficulty in this play is not the catch
it's the throw on the run
i mean off balance not able to square
and take us on the run and that is just
a very fine play
lead runner is vr at third with lindor
at second and smith at first and the
mets trying to break a 2-2 tie here with
alonso swinging a high fly ball deep to
left down the line it's going to stay in
the park peterson moving to the corner
makes the catch beyond tags at third
he's coming to the plate he'll score
standing as the throw goes to third
holding it second is lenore holding at
first is smith but give pete alonso
credit for a sacrifice fly and the mets
have a three to two lead and that's part
of the met's arsenal that has been
missing this year the ability to elevate
in those situations to get a run home
he's retired aidan arose since ian hop
hit one over the third base bag for a
single in the fourth and now hop up for
the third time tonight swung out in this
strike three side retired that's ten
strikeouts for taiwan walker who is now
retired nine in a row i want walkers at
all-star 2-15 e-r-a at the moment
more than a strikeout period he's only
given up three home runs in 67 innings
this season and now sergio alcantara
will be the batter on the inside corner
strike three called it's the 11th
strikeout for walker it ties his career
high so two out now the veteran ortega
will back for the first time
strike three called uneven dozen from
taiwan walker another wonderful night
for taiwan walker doesn't strike out for
the first time in his career 12 in a row
retired the guy on the met side is a
free agent late in the winter and he has
turned out to be a godsend for this
men's pitching staff peterson wisdom and
baez
due up here in the eighth as seth lugo
takes over swung out and missed strike
three peterson tried to hold his swing
and could not had a 95 mile an hour
fastball
you're looking for something else that
is a swing that you kind of want if you
can delete it
you want to delete it
and delete it twice so desire comes back
better off with control alt delete
here's the one two to baez fastball
swung out and missed strike three what a
performance in that eighth inning from
seth lugo using every club in his bag to
strike out two and get the cubs in order
boy is he ever a welcome sight back in
that nets bullpen so runners at the
corners with two out for vr who's had a
terrific night at the play to single a
double in a walk he's two for three
bouncing ball left side feel about
wisdom throws to first and rizzo able to
stay on the bag a low bad throw but
anthony saved a throwing error great
catch by rizzo
and the inning comes to an end seth ludo
looking for his first save of the season
he's got a dozen saves in his career
three of them last year
first base runner since the fourth
inning for the cubs
jake mariznick will run for contreras at
first base
leaning aligner to right center that's a
base hit hustling into the gap as pallor
to cut it off elizabeth on his way to
third he's going to be waved home the
really threat of the fight by guillerme
the slide he is out at the plate harris
the third base coach giving mariznick
the green light and that troll had him
by a couple of uh steps at the plate two
out two on two and two to al contra he
struck him out and the ball game is over
and the mets have taken the first two
from the cubs